Optimal at this altitude,
I can run flat out for a half mile before my hands start shaking.
I'm a cybernetic organism.
Living tissue over
this episode is brought to you by teeter.
I am so thrilled to have connected with these guys because I've used teeter
products for many,
many years.
I've traveled around the country and the world with teeter products and I'm
sitting about 15 feet in my home from one of their inversion tables and we're
going to talk more about all of that.
One of my rituals is hanging and I should say not really that it's a maintenance
and performance program.
I hang not just in the morning potentially,
but particularly after a day of bearing weight,
whether that includes weight training and Jersey Gregorich world record holder
insists on this type of inversion therapy after training or just wearing heavy
backpack around a few minutes goes a long way towards better sleep.
In my case,
less back pain,
neck pain,
leg pain.
It's not a panacea obviously,
but inversion therapy,
which uses gravity in your own body weight to decompress the spinal relief
pressure on the discs and surrounding nerves seems to help with a whole slew of
conditions.
And just as a general maintenance program,
it's one of my favorite things to do.
So what to say about that teeter?
Why teeter teeter is the best known name in inversion table since 1981 more than
3 million people have put their trust and teeter tutor is also the only
inversion table brand that has been both safety certified by underwriters
laboratories.
That's Ul for you people in that industry,
you will recognize it and registered with the FDA as a class one medical device
and they're giving a very special offer just to you guys,
my listeners for a limited time that you can get the teeter inversion table with
bonus accessories,
which I have a bunch of again in the room next to me and a free pair of gravity
boots so that you can invert at home or take the boots with you to the gym.
So these gravity boots,
I have three separate pairs of gravity boots bought with my own monies in three
different cities that I've had for a very,
very long time because I don't want to travel with them necessarily.
They look kind of like ski boots,
but without the foot portion,
and they hook you upside down so you can take them really anywhere you want to
go to get this deal,
which is a savings of over $148 it's very specific,
so maybe it's 149 you have to go to teeter.com forward slash Tim,
that's [inaudible] dot com forward slash.
Tim,
t.
E.
T.
R.
You also get free shipping,
a 60 day money back guarantee and free returns.
So why not try it out?
Remember,
you can only get the teeter inversion table with bonus accessories and a free
pair of gravity boots by going to teeter.com forward,
Tim.
So if you're thinking yourself,
what the hell is this thing he's talking about?
I can't even envision it in my head.
Well,
take a look at the photos.
Go to teeter.com forward slash.
Tim
this episode is brought to you by helix sleep.
Last year I committed to making sleep a top priority,
trying to fix onset insomnia or continuing to fix that depth of sleep,
quality of sleep.
I tracked a lot.
I tested a lot and I revisited really everything from the daily routine to the
surfaces.
I slept on playing with the chilly pad,
whatever,
and when I moved to Austin I got all new beds including mattresses from Helix,
working with the world's leading sleep experts.
Certainly some of them.
He looks sleep developed mattresses personalized to your preferences and sleep
style to make sure that you can have the best sleep possible without costing
thousands upon thousands of dollars.
He looks sleep has recently added a new layer to customize sleep with the helix
pillow.
The all new pillows are fully adjustable so you can achieve perfect comfort
regardless of sleep position or body type or if you're a shifty type like me,
I move around quite a bit when I sleep.
Just take their simple two to three minute sleep quiz to get started and that
will help ensure that they can build a mattress or pillow that you will love the
mattress,
whatever this be spoke mattresses that you arrive at a we'll get to you within a
week and the shipping is completely free.
You can try the mattress for 100 nights and if you're not completely happy
they'll pick it up and offer a full refund.
I tested that refund policy because I test all of the sponsors and kick the
tires a lot.
We tested it and they came through and making sure that we got ultimately the
right mattress for my body.
Type to personalize your sleep experience,
visit Helix,
sleep.com forward slash Tim and you'll receive up to $125 off your mattress
order.
That's helix sleep,
h e l I x sleep.com forward slash Tim for up to $125 off your order.
Hello,
boys and girls,
ladies and germs.
This is Tim Ferriss and welcome to a very special episode of the Tim Ferriss
show.
I'm going to start this off with a quote,
quote with the telescope was for astronomy and the microscope for biology.
Psychedelics will be for the understanding of the human mind that is tributed to
Stanislav Grof.
This episode you're going to hear,
I've been looking forward to recording for more than a year now.
It might be the most important episode that I've put out in the last two to
three years,
so please trust me and give it a full listen.
Even if you don't think it will interest you at all,
it will surprise you,
perhaps shock you and definitely make you think differently.
Michael Pollan's newest book,
and this is his first podcast about it is my new favorite of his.
It is titled how to Change Your Mind.
Subtitle,
what the new science of psychedelics teaches us about consciousness,
dying,
addiction,
depression,
and transcendence.
This is an episode that we'll explore not just the science and applications of
Psychedelics,
but also Michael's personal exploration.
It's quite a wild ride for those who don't know who Michael Pollan is on Twitter
at Michael Paulin,
he's the author of seven previous books including cooked food rules in defense
of food,
the Omnivore's dilemma.
Also a great book and the botany of desire.
Also a fantastic book,
all of which were New York Times bestsellers,
a long time contributor to the New York Times magazine.
He also teaches writing at Harvard and the University of California at Berkeley,
where he is the John S and James L.
Knight,
professor of Science Journalism in 2010 time magazine named him one of the 100
most influential people in the world.
This is also where I want to make a public announcement,
and that is partially due to Michael's book.
I am committing $1 million over the next few years to supporting scientific
study of psychedelic compounds.
This is for me by far the largest commitment to research and nonprofits that
I've ever made,
and if you'd like to perhaps join me in supporting at a higher level,
check out Tim dot.
Blog Ford.
Slash.
Science.
It's Tim dot.
Blog forward slash.
Science,
but why would I do this across the board?
I've done a number of things in the scientific realm and the molecules discussed
in this episode and some incredible clinical results from well designed studies
have absolutely captured my attention over the last two years and after waiting
in and supporting some smaller studies,
seeing the results,
I've decided to go all in on scientists exploring this area.
It just seems to be an Archimedes lever for potentially solving a wide range of
root cause problems.
Instead of playing whack a mole with symptoms one by one.
So this episode will explain why I'm so goddamn excited and all that preamble
out of the way.
Grab a cup of coffee,
relax,
put your seat back,
settle in.
And I really hope you enjoy this conversation as much as I did.
Without further ado,
here is Michael Pollan.
Michael,
welcome to the show.
Thank you Tim.
Good to be here.
I am so thrilled to be sitting down to have this conversation.
And I thought back to when we first met and I believe I owe some thanks to Matt
Mullenweg,
the CEO of Automattic,
because I believe that I attended an event he had organized that might have been
for the Omnivore's dilemma.
I think it was perhaps,
uh,
in defense of food.
But I've,
I've followed your career for so long and read so many of your books.
I thought one place we could start is with the conception of Michael Pollan as
food writer and
a common misconception.
Perhaps we could start off with you just how the
new book came to be.
How did you end up writing this new book?
Sure.
Well to go back,
I think we met at a benefit for grist.
Oh,
that's right.
That is right.
That was also involved.
And that was around the time of independence of food or food rules or something.
Yeah.
At a Tony Conrad's house.
That's right.
That's absolutely right.
Back a few years.
Yeah.
But I think that was the first time we met.
Um,
so yeah,
this book does certainly seem like a departure for me.
And in some ways it is.
Um,
but in other ways I see it as very continuous with the kind of work I've been
doing.
As I see it.
I think of myself as a,
as a kind of nature writer.
I really like writing about the engagement of humans with other species.
And I've been doing that since my first book,
which was a book called second nature,
which was really about what was going on in my garden.
Um,
and I always been interested in the fact that we have these symbiotic
relationships that were active participants in nature,
not just spectators.
Uh,
and then we have,
um,
uh,
and that the,
the,
the usual American way of thinking about nature that we inherit from Thoreau and
Emerson and John Muir is of a very passive relationship.
And I've always,
as a gardener,
I've always been interested in the more active relationship,
the way we use plants and the way they in turn use us.
Um,
so if that's the kind of spine or the,
the trunk of my work,
all the food work is kind of a big fat branch off of that.
Um,
and that's,
you know,
looking at what is one of our most powerful engagements with the natural world,
uh,
which is agriculture,
which,
you know,
changes nature more than anything else we do.
Really.
Um,
so I've been on that branch for now for books,
I guess,
and uh,
but I've never lost interest in the other ways we engage with the natural world.
And one of the most curious of these,
which I touched on in a,
in a book called Botany of desire,
was the fact that we use plants to change our experience of consciousness and a
very select group of plants and fungi has evolved,
uh,
the chemistry that does that with varying degrees of,
of,
um,
disruption.
Um,
and I've always been curious as to why such a desire and it is a universal human
desire.
There is not a culture on earth that doesn't use some plant or fungi,
fungi to change consciousness with one notable exception,
the Inuit.
And the only reason they don't is none of that stuff grows there.
Um,
and uh,
so what's that desire about what good is it for us to change consciousness?
Why do,
why do people seek it?
So that's,
you know,
that's kind of been a theme of my work that I've never fully explored in a book
until this one,
until how to change your mind.
So there is that continuity in my mind,
uh,
and it is part of a larger narrative that I've always been interested in.
And then there's the fact that I'm intensely interested in health.
Uh,
I've been writing about health,
uh,
in my last couple of books on food.
Um,
you know,
we have a situation where,
uh,
our biggest physical health problems or chronic diseases linked to our diet,
um,
but we also of course suffer from,
a real crisis and mental health.
And that also made me very interested to take a look at psychedelics,
uh,
since they promise,
to,
uh,
to contribute to solving that problem.
Did,
did,
did that interest in exploring psychedelics?
This is going to be very,
uh,
the mental like conversation chronologically.
We'll probably bounce around quite a bit.
Did that begin with the article about psychedelic psychotherapy in the New
Yorker called the trip treatment?
Did it proceed that,
how did,
how did that piece yeah,
cop come about.
That was my first real foray.
I think I talked about psychedelics briefly in botany of desire and quoted
Aldous Huxley and the idea of the reducing valve and,
um,
whether we had a more accurate or less accurate picture of the world when,
uh,
when high.
Um,
but yeah,
my spirit,
my first serious forward foray was,
uh,
I had heard this remarkable,
about this remarkable research using psychedelics silicide been in particular
magic mushrooms or the ingredient in magic mushrooms to treat people,
uh,
who had cancer diagnoses.
And this seems so improbable to me.
I couldn't imagine wanting to take a sec Adeleke when confronting my mortality,
um,
that I became very curious to explore it.
Um,
and so embarked on what was almost a year long project,
uh,
looking at,
silicide siliciden and talking to dozens of people,
cancer patients,
some of them still alive,
some of them no longer alive.
And how this single experience,
a high dose psilocybin experience administered,
uh,
with a guide,
um,
you know,
in a very controlled setting had completely reset their thinking about
mortality,
had given them a mystical experience that,
uh,
dissolve their egos and made them think about their place in the world in such a
novel way or their sense of their own self interest as so broad that dying,
uh,
lost its sting.
Uh,
and,
uh,
completely in some cases.
I remember this one woman I talked to,
uh,
who had,
um,
uh,
her name was a dyna bizarre.
She was a figure skating instructor in New York City and she was in her early
sixties,
and she had ovarian cancer and she was absolutely paralyzed by the fear of a
recurrence.
Uh,
even though she,
you know,
had a successful course of therapy and she,
she had a suicide in a journey.
And,
uh,
she went into her body and under her rib cage,
she confronted this black mass.
It wasn't her tumor because it wasn't in her,
uh,
you know,
were her ovaries would be.
It was,
uh,
under her rib cage.
And she realized it wasn't her tumor.
It was a fear.
And she screamed at it.
She said,
get the fuck out of my body.
And she said,
advantaged.
And from then on she had no fear.
And in the article for the New Yorker,
I w I did the usual play it safe journalist thing where I said,
and after the experience,
her fear had been substantially diminished or something that I thought would
slip,
pass the fact checkers.
And
as we tend to do,
and uh,
they called her though in check the quote with her and,
uh,
and she said,
no,
that's completely wrong.
It was not diminished.
My fear was eliminated.
And what she explained is I learned during that psilocybin trip that though I
couldn't control the cancer,
I could control the fear.
And that was just life changing for her.
Um,
so reading about these experiences,
um,
which seem,
you know,
too good to be true,
almost,
uh,
almost implausible.
I became more and more interested in going deeper.
You know,
as a journalist there,
there are two kinds of articles we write there.
They're the ones where we exhausted the subject and we're so sick of it,
we can't wait to move on.
And then they're the ones where we realize,
you know,
I've only scratched the surface here and this was one of those I had only
scratch the surface.
There was so much more to learn.
And then there was also this mounting curiosity to have some experiences in my
own.
We're definitely going to,
uh,
explore that terrain.
I thought a one very helpful aspect of the book is the glossary of terms that
you include in the beginning.
And it's actually in the end of the printed version.
Oh,
it is.
All right.
So I received a free prepublication copy
into the back.
It just felt a little text booky to confront it first.
It is very textbooky,
but it,
it helps provide people with whether at the back of the book,
at the beginning,
uh,
definitions that I think can,
can help to inform the conversation.
So for people who are,
who have heard the term no doubt psychedelic or psychedelics
but are unclear on exactly what that refers to,
can you,
could you define that?
What are psychedelics?
Sure.
I'd be happy to.
I'd be happy to try.
You know,
one of the interesting aspects of the story of the history of what we'll call
psychedelics,
uh,
for reasons I'll explain is that the name kept changing because people really
didn't understand these molecules.
They were so strange.
Uh,
so at first they were called psychometrics.
this is in the early fifties,
soon after LSD was made available to researchers and a psychotomimetic,
basically men,
it was a psychoactive drug that mimics psychosis.
And lots of psychiatrists would look at the,
what happened to people and say,
well,
they're having a psychotic episode turned out to be wrong,
but it sure looked that way.
And,
um,
and then they,
then other people call it a psycholytic,
uh,
which means mind loosening.
And they were using it in a,
basically in your typical talk therapy session,
uh,
as a way to loosen a lytic means mine loosening,
people's defenses and allow them to get in touch with subconscious,
uh,
thoughts and emotions.
Psychedelic as a term is coined in 1957,
uh,
by,
a key figure in this history named Humphry Osmond.
Osmond is an English psychiatrist who moves to Saskatchewan because the
provincial government was willing to let him study whatever he wanted,
which happened to be a Mescalin and LSD.
And they had a very progressive health department in Saskatchewan.
And,
um,
he w he got involved with Aldous Huxley and in fact,
is the person responsible for giving Aldous Huxley his first Mescalin
experience.
Uh,
and they corresponded extensively as people use to do.
And in one of their correspondence,
they were,
they were trying to come up with a better word for these drugs because they
simply didn't believe it was true that it made people crazy.
In fact,
they believed they could make people saying,
so they went back and forth and Osmund ironically enough,
not the brilliant writer came up with the term that stuck and that was
psychedelic.
And that essentially all that means is mind manifesting.
That these are compounds that help the mind manifest its its deepest,
uh,
qualities and uh,
it caught on.
And,
um,
we think of it as a very kind of sixties terms associated with Timothy leary
and,
and the counterculture,
but in fact it was coined by a psychiatrist in the 50s.
Um,
so it's simply means mine manifesting and I use it to refer to what are
sometimes called the classical psychedelics.
Um,
I tend not to think of Mgma as a secondary,
even though some people do or,
or cannabis as a secondary tick,
but that group of chemicals that include Mescalin Dmt,
uh,
silicide been magic mushrooms and Lsd and there,
and there's a handful of others that are unified by the fact that they work on
similar receptor network in the brain and have roughly similar effects on the
mind on,
you know,
on the phenomenology of the experience.
So that's really when I talk about psychedelics,
that's what I've gotten.
Mine and the by phenomenology you mean the subjective reporting of this
subjective experience that felt experience?
Yeah,
it's a very fancy word for how it feels.
Why did you dedicate this book to your father?
Ah,
well,
um,
for a couple reasons.
Some of which I didn't understand till I finished the book.
Um,
I did it because my dad was very sick for most of the time I was writing it.
He,
he himself had terminal cancer and died of lung cancer and uh,
earlier this year in January.
Um,
so I wanted,
it was my last chance to dedicate a book to him or at least one that he would
see.
He didn't get to read it.
Um,
so I thought I would do it,
but
as I've thought about it since I realized this book is,
you know very much about him,
uh,
a friend of mine read the book and said,
wow,
your father is on every page.
And I didn't know what that meant exactly,
but I've since given it some thought and I realized that one of the reasons I
got so interested in the experience of cancer and,
and,
and that,
that confrontation with one's mortality is that my dad was going through that.
But unlike the patients I was talking to,
the volunteers and the suicide and experience,
he really didn't want to talk about it.
And it was just a conversation we couldn't have.
And we had a lot of conversations in his last year or two.
Um,
but for whatever reason,
I don't really understand how he was processing a,
what was coming because he really wouldn't share it.
And so in a sense,
I was,
I was having conversations I wanted to have with him,
although I was certainly afraid to,
in some ways,
I was having those conversations with these other people,
these,
these strangers who I got to know,
uh,
and,
and hearing how they thought about their death and how silicide been changed,
how they thought about their death really became a proxy for a conversation I
never had with my father.
What effect did that have on you?
I mean,
if,
if anything jumps out,
I mean,
is there any salient effects that had on you?
Did you,
did you,
did you end up feeling a sense of closure or resolution in some way?
Uh,
you know,
in a way I wish my father had been able to have one of these experiences.
I don't know that he would have gone for it.
Um,
you know,
he's such a different generation.
He was probably too old to qualify.
He was 88 when he died.
Um,
but it's kind of a black box.
Uh,
you know,
that was a generation,
didn't always talk about these things.
And,
um,
uh,
I do think it had an effect on me in that having given so much thought to death
and the process and the afterlife as psychedelics makes you do.
Um,
I think in his last weeks and months and days I was more available to him than I
would have been.
Um,
you know,
I think that I was not,
um,
as fearful or as defensive is probably a better word.
You know,
one of the things our egos defended us against his death.
One of the big things.
And so when we're confronted by it,
we figure out a million ways to think about something else or,
or turn away if we can.
But I was very present for his death.
I was with him and my mother in the apartment for the last week.
And I didn't feel there was any barrier.
I felt like I was able to say everything I needed to say to be physically
available to him.
Um,
so in a sense,
I think my own,
my own psychedelic experiences in the amount of thought I'd give it to,
to dying,
uh,
because of that article I'd worked on,
um,
probably made me a,
a better caregiver in some ways and better able to process,
uh,
what was happening.
And,
and you know,
I guess I did a lot of preparation to,
cause I saw it coming for a couple of years.
Um,
uh,
that takes,
you know,
that takes away none of the power of the experience.
Um,
but I do think if,
you know,
it's funny,
uh,
some,
some journalists just started doing interviews on this book and one of the
questions you get asked is how did your own experiences change you?
And that's a hard question to answer.
It's,
it's subtle in some ways,
but it was my wife who said,
well,
uh,
I really think you would've,
you would've been different around your father at the end if you hadn't had
those experiences.
And you know,
I think she's probably right
based on all of my reading of your work based on,
uh,
the,
the conversations I've observed you having a and our limited exchanges that
we've had,
you've always struck me as a very open minded,
uh,
journalist while very skeptical,
which is a good combination for the profession you've chosen.
What were you most skeptical of going into the process of saying,
considering a book on this topic?
And did you go in with the intention of having your own experiences?
I didn't go in with that intention when I started the New Yorker article.
Um,
I didn't know it was possible to have.
Obviously you can have a psychedelic experience if you can find the drugs.
But I mean to have the sort of orchestrated guided experience,
which I think is if people need to understand is a fundamentally different way
of using the same chemical,
but the,
the experience is like very different.
Um,
and uh,
it was actually in the course of working on that article that I kept getting
like these whispers that there was this underground and uh,
that,
you know,
there was a kind of shadow world and not too far away from the,
um,
the,
you know,
the legit researchers.
I was,
I was interviewing and,
um,
so I,
I started getting inklings that that might be possible.
Um,
but I,
I'm not,
uh,
um,
I'm not a psychonaut.
Uh,
and I was not,
uh,
I had very little experience.
I mean,
it was kind of odd.
I just kind of came of age,
a little wrinkle in time where there weren't a lot of psychedelics around.
And by the time they were available to me,
I was,
I was terrified to them.
I'm sort of more a product of the moral panic against psychedelics.
Then of the psychedelic sixties.
I mean,
just to give me an idea,
I was 12 during the summer of love.
I was 14 during a Woodstock.
So this,
I was a little,
you know,
uh,
I came a little late to the party and the party was getting pretty sour already.
Um,
you know,
the scene in San Francisco had gotten really sour and,
uh,
there was a lot of bad information but scary information about psychedelics that
were out there.
So this wasn't a natural thing for me.
And you know,
what you call my skepticism is journalistic skepticism,
but it's also,
you know,
Plano fear and,
and you know,
wondering,
is this for real?
Um,
I did have skepticism.
I think that the results of these studies,
which hadn't been published when I published on them,
it was quite,
it was very much to the New Yorkers credit.
They were willing to let me do 14,000 words on essentially a scientific research
that hadn't been peer reviewed yet.
Um,
and,
uh,
but I gradually became convinced by the,
you know,
the authority of the people who were talking to me that they had,
had,
had these transformative experiences.
Um,
I tend to,
uh,
but I do write about psychedelics and I think that's,
this is somewhat unique about the book with one foot outside of this world and
only one foot in it.
Um,
and I think that that distance is very important,
um,
for various reasons.
I think it's important to remain critical as a journalist and when you see
things that are being hyped,
um,
and you know,
that that may well happen with psychedelics.
Um,
uh,
it's something I,
I,
I'm concerned about.
Um,
but also as a way in for readers who may not be experienced or may have their
own doubts or fears.
Um,
I become a surrogate for the reluctant a traveler.
And,
um,
and that's,
you know,
that's always been part of my work.
I,
I don't like to write as an expert.
Um,
another reason I sort of moved off of food,
at least for the time being is I really like writing closer to the beginning of
the learning curve.
Um,
when everything is still new and exciting and I,
and I can bring a sense of wonder to it.
I don't think readers really like being lectured at by a highly experienced
experts.
Um,
I think they'd rather come on a journey of a or an education with you.
And so I was outside this world and dipping my toe in,
you know,
first kind of very tentatively and then,
kind of my whole foot,
uh,
and then much larger part of my body.
Um,
but it wasn't a natural progression for me and it wasn't an easy progression.
I mean,
we'll talk about this,
but my,
you know,
each of my own psychedelic journeys,
um,
that I had for the book were preceded by a sleepless night of incredible anxiety
where I was just a ping pong ball with arguments going back and forth.
Like,
are you crazy?
You know,
you're 60 years old,
you could have a heart attack up there on that mountain.
And this guy is not going to call nine one one.
He's,
he's worried about his freedom.
Um,
and,
and then the other side saying,
well come on,
aren't you curious about what you might learn?
And,
and by the way you've got a book deadline coming up,
you've got to do this.
And so I had every,
every time it was like that,
it never got easier.
Um,
and uh,
you know,
I realize now that was my ego defending itself against the assault to come.
And of course our egos have command of our rational faculties so they make
really good arguments and mine was definitely making a good argument to me,
but thank God I ignored him.
Could you talk a bit about what we know or suspect about the neuroscience behind
how these compounds may have the effects they have?
And just as please jump into,
correct me at any point cause you,
you are certainly better versed with,
with all of this,
but when you mentioned for people who,
who don't have the background,
when you mentioned guided experiences or supervised environments and the New
Yorker piece,
I'll just give a little bit of background for people who may not be aware that
that includes certainly underground options,
but also includes,
uh,
universities like Johns Hopkins,
Nyu,
and ever expanding list and,
uh,
some very,
very credible researchers.
Uh,
certainly some who,
who would be considered the researchers,
researcher and scientist.
Uh,
what do we know of the science?
Because these,
these compounds have been so mysterious in a sense.
They've been so continually used for certainly centuries,
if not millennia by different civilizations.
Uh,
you can find totems from the mass attacks going back thousands of years and so
on.
What,
what,
what new insights or theories have,
uh,
have caught your attention in the,
the scientific realm?
Well,
the neuroscience I just have to say is absolutely fascinating.
And for me intellectually,
that was kind of one of the most exciting parts of the research was,
was learning what were,
what these chemicals
are teaching us about the mind and the brain.
Uh,
you know,
there's a famous quote by Stanislav Grof who was a,
um,
a check emigre psychiatrist who worked with psychedelics extensively when there
were legal in his practice.
And he said,
I think this is in the early seventies.
He said something that,
you know,
sounds outrageous.
Uh,
which is that psychedelics would be for the study of the mind,
what the telescope was for astronomy and what the microscope was for biology.
That's a pretty big claim.
And,
um,
uh,
and it sounded like hyperbole to me when I first heard it,
but having spent a lot of time in these labs with these scientists,
I no longer think it's impossible that he's right.
He may well be right.
Um,
but that said,
you know,
the brain is still very poorly understood consciousness even more poorly
understood.
So it's important to understand that everything I'm about to tell you is,
um,
uh,
you know,
hypothesis.
Um,
and some goes a little further than a hypothesis,
but there's still a lot of mysteries.
The first one being how does,
let's say,
you,
you ingest LSD or psilocybin and we know that it links to a certain kind of,
uh,
brain receptor,
the,
uh,
h two five a or a receptor,
which is the same one that's that a SSRI engage with.
And that sounds like,
oh,
we really understand something,
but,
but what happens downstream of that?
We don't have a clue how you get from that activity,
activation of those receptors to the phenomenology,
the felt experience of,
um,
of the drugs.
Um,
so there's,
there's a lot we don't understand,
but one of the most interesting clues,
uh,
has come from the work done,
especially at imperial college in London.
Uh,
but also it's now happening at other places in Switzerland and at Hopkins too,
to image the brains of people on psychedelics.
Um,
by image,
I mean use Fmri or some of these other modalities,
um,
to see what's going on in the brain when people are under the influence.
And the biggest takeaway from that work,
uh,
and this is in papers that,
Robin Carhart,
Harris and imperial college has published,
is that contrary to what the neuroscientist expected,
which was that the brain would kind of light up with extra activity,
uh,
because there was such,
you know,
visual and auditory fireworks going on during the experience.
They found that,
um,
activity in the brain was actually depressed by psychedelics,
particularly in one network.
This was a network I had never heard of it before until I started doing this
work.
And it was only discovered about 15 years ago by a neuroscientist,
American neuroscientist at Washington University named Marcus Raichle.
And that is the default mode network called that because this is kind of where
the brain goes when it's not busy.
Um,
it's where you go to ruminate,
worry,
a daydream.
Um,
and it was discovered when they were administering Fmr Ris,
uh,
to people and needed to get a baseline.
And they would tell people,
don't do anything.
Just lie there and don't,
you know,
no tasks.
And they would see that.
Oh,
interesting.
The brain is actually quite active when you're doing nothing.
And this part of it is very active.
This part is a linked set of structures that include the prefrontal Cortex,
the posterior cingulate cortex.
These are both in the Cortex,
which is the evolutionarily most recent part of layer of the brain on the
outside.
Um,
and,
and then those link down into deeper older structures like,
uh,
that are involved with memory,
and um,
emotions.
Um,
and it appears to be a very important hub.
Uh,
the brain is a hierarchical system and the default mode network kind of is in
charge,
uh,
is a regulator of the whole.
And um,
it's involved in a range of metacognitive,
uh,
functions.
Uh,
that includes self reflection and rumination time travel.
That's thinking about the past and thinking about the future,
um,
theory of mind.
Uh,
that's the ability to imagine mental states or attribute mental states to
others.
Um,
and uh,
the what is called the autobiographical memory,
uh,
the autobiographical self.
Forgive me.
Um,
this is kind of where we integrate what's happening to us with the narrative we
have of who we are.
Uh,
which is a mix of,
you know,
everything that's happened to us before are the parts of our biography we think
about and our objectives for the future.
And to have an a,
a sense of self that's consistent over time,
something we prize,
even though it's probably completely illusory.
Um,
that work of constructing that happens in a part of the parts of the default
mode network.
So you could say it's kind of the seat of the self or the ego to the extent that
we can say that.
And,
um,
and how interesting that this particular network important as it is,
gets,
goes offline or at least has activity diminished.
And,
and this is really interesting.
The more precipitous the drop in activity in the default mode network,
the more likely someone is liable to report that they experienced ego
dissolution,
that that,
uh,
experience that's common on a high dose of psychedelics.
That can either be terrifying or absolutely ecstatic of having your sense of
self disappear or melt or dissolve.
And which is then followed by this merging with,
um,
you know,
the larger world,
the nature of the universe,
other people.
And,
um,
uh,
so that seems to be involved with the,
you know,
dimunition of activity in this,
in this particular network.
So that gives us a window into the self and into spiritual experience because
that experience of ego dissolution feels to people like a mystical experience
feels like a,
it's very spiritual.
This sense of,
you know,
transcending this bag of bones we are and,
and,
and actually connect with,
with larger entities.
And it's that experience to that,
um,
may make it easier to,
uh,
die in that ego dissolution is a kind of rehearsal for death.
Uh,
giving up yourself and then seeing,
and this was for me the most incredible thing was that,
uh,
your ego could die,
but you still perceive you're,
there's still a consciousness,
another consciousness.
And um,
and I think that that's enormously comforting to a,
to people.
So anyway,
from a neuroscientific point of view,
this is a really interesting insight and psychedelics gave it to us.
There are two other things I want to say about it.
That's,
it's also even more interesting.
One is that when they,
when other researchers at Yale started scanning the brains of really experienced
meditators,
you know,
people would 10,000 hours,
we really know how to,
how to meditate.
Um,
their scans look very similar to the people on psychedelics on Siliciden,
uh,
that they,
to that meditation is another way to quiet the default mode network.
And my guess is there's several others too.
My guess is it's quieted when you're,
um,
uh,
you know,
when you fast,
uh,
s uh,
you know,
when you're on a vision quest,
when you go into sensory deprivation,
um,
my guess is that all these powerful experiences may well involve alternate
modalities for shutting off,
requiring the default mode network.
So that's a big takeaway,
uh,
and I think,
um,
will be significant in the future.
The other point I want to make about that and the neuroscience is that,
uh,
also coming out of Robin Carhart Harris,
his lab,
um,
was they mapped,
uh,
connections.
They call it the connectome in the,
in the human brain.
And that changes during the experience when you turn off the default mode
network,
which,
uh,
Robin refers to as the orchestra conductor or corporate executive or capital
city of the brain.
He has all these wonderful metaphors when that goes offline,
other parts of the brain and other networks that don't ordinarily talk to each
other,
strike up conversations.
And if you look at this image,
which is reprinted in my book,
actually they did it in color in the middle of the book.
I didn't even know they could do this.
Uh,
toward the end of the book.
Um,
you see that what had been this,
this,
uh,
set of principle,
you know,
main thoroughfares,
connecting different networks in the brain.
Suddenly you get lots of little roads,
uh,
new connections.
Um,
myriad new connections get established basically because probably because the
default mode network is not requiring everybody come through that hub.
And,
uh,
so you have,
for example,
perhaps emotion centers talking directly to your visual Cortex,
which Lo and behold could allow you to see things you're,
you're feeling,
um,
you know,
could could result in lucid nations.
Those new connections May,
and now I'm being speculative,
may manifest as new perspectives,
new ideas,
new means,
new metaphors.
Um,
but the point is that by temporarily,
you know,
disrupting the order of the brain,
a new order forms and that order may have incredible value it at either the
level of mental health and psychology or at the level of creativity.
Um,
and that's what we need to get into right now.
What,
what happens with those new connections?
Do they endure or not?
Uh,
and are there ways to,
uh,
help them endure longer?
The visualization that you mentioned is so
the difference is so pronounced and uh,
it's really something to behold.
So I certainly encourage people to just take a moment to soak the image in when
they have a chance to look at it.
And it's not hard to find online too.
It's not hard to find online.
And what I wanted to,
I mean,
certainly these compounds are not panaceas.
They don't fix everything
and,
and they do have risks.
I mean,
I think we should talk,
oh,
we're absolutely going to talk about the risks up,
but before we get to that,
I wanted to go back to the studies that have been done and to ask you what
studies have most perhaps shocked you or surprise you or have stuck with you?
And just for purposes of a supposed sharing on my side,
the studies are really wide ranging and many studies had been performed in the,
uh,
suppose,
well,
I'm not sure when the early fifties and early sixties,
but,
uh,
the,
even looking at the more recent studies related to smoking cessation or
different forms of addiction,
certainly end of life anxiety,
uh,
treatment resistant depression,
dear a number of characteristics that have been really surprising to me when
looking at the results.
But I'd be curious to hear if there are any,
uh,
related to the magnitude persistence or anything of effects that have been
particularly memorable for you.
Yeah.
Well,
I mean,
the first one that was really memorable to me was the first one I read and this
was a 2006 study by a done at Johns Hopkins.
In the lab of Roland Griffiths who I believe,
you know pretty well.
And,
um,
this was a kind of wild study because it didn't purport to have any practical
utility at all.
It wasn't,
uh,
it had nothing to do with health or healing people.
It was really an attempt to see if silicide been,
could be used to occasion.
That's the verb they use to occasion,
uh,
profound mystical experiences and people,
and the title of this paper is kind of hilarious.
You know,
a high dose of Psilocybin can occasion profound mystical experiences in people
that are,
have you no lasting value or something like that.
Um,
I don't have it quite right,
but it's,
uh,
it,
it just stood out.
His weight scientists do this.
That's pretty cool.
Um,
and what's a mystical experience doing in a scientific experiment?
but it,
in a way,
this was the predicate of all the research to come,
uh,
in this,
renaissance that's going on because,
um,
they had found,
first they had proven that you could safely administer these drugs in this
environment,
and that with a very high percentage,
you could induce this kind of experience that people would report as one of the
three,
a two or three most meaningful experiences in their lives,
comparable to the birth of a child or the death of a parent.
Um,
the fact that you could induce such an experience in a laboratory reliably with
a mushroom,
uh,
well that,
that kind of blew my mind.
And,
and I talked,
I interviewed many people in that trial and,
uh,
and it was really interesting to hear their experience.
These are,
these are so called healthy normals.
Um,
so they didn't have a pathology.
They weren't dying.
Um,
and they were kind of spiritually inclined.
Uh,
it was definitely,
um,
you know,
it seemed to me a common denominator of the people,
the volunteers,
um,
but that,
that this drug would create an experience that was indistinguishable from
mystical experiences as we have them in the literature as they were recorded by
the great mystics of,
uh,
of all time.
Uh,
and,
and all the writers who've talked about mystical experience from,
you know,
Whitman to Emerson,
to Tennessee.
Um,
so I thought that was a really cool study.
and the testimony of the people in it was very interesting.
It was also interesting that,
um,
you know,
followup,
they crunch that data very carefully,
and they discovered that,
um,
uh,
significant statistically significant percentage of people who had had these
silicide experiences had actually had changes in their personality that we're
enduring.
Um,
psychologist divide personality up into five traits.
And I'm not gonna remember them all,
but it's things like conscientiousness and neuroticism,
extraversion openness,
and I forget the fifth.
Um,
but,
um,
openness,
uh,
which correlates with a,
you know,
tolerance for other people's points of view,
ability to,
to take in lots of,
um,
surprising information,
uh,
creativity.
Um,
actually it was increased a statistically significant increase in openness.
and that's,
it's very rare that personality changes in adults at all.
And the idea that a mushroom could induce such a change was really striking.
Now this has yet to be reproduced,
this particular result.
But,
um,
uh,
whether there are lasting changes in personality of people who take
psychedelics,
I think is a really rich topic to explore [inaudible] and definitely deserve
more work.
The smoking study you alluded to,
I thought it was also fascinating.
Um,
you know,
here you have one of the hardest of all habits to Kik.
Um,
and,
uh,
80% of people who went through this process,
which involved two or three psychedelic trips on psilocybin and some cognitive
behavioral therapy,
uh,
in between,
um,
80% were confirmed abstinent ha had,
we're not smoking at the six month mark.
And that number fell to a,
I think it was 67% after a year.
Um,
this is a small pilot study open label,
which means everybody knew they were getting psilocybin and nobody got a
placebo.
Um,
but that's,
that's pretty impressive.
And in fact,
67% success after a year is better than anything else that's out there.
So this study needs to be a reproduction and it is not,
it's happening.
Yeah.
Sorry to interrupt,
but also as I understand it,
it's not a marginal difference in efficacy compared to the standard of care for
looking at alternative treatments.
Uh,
I mean the,
the Delta,
at least with this preliminary study as you,
as you mentioned,
open label is something,
I mean,
I,
I somebody out there on the Internet can certainly correct me if I want to save
as perhaps the alternative sort of option B more traditionally speaking,
be somewhere in the 20s and in terms of efficacy at the six month mark,
looking at absence rates,
I could be,
I could be getting the wrong fit.
Um,
there's a,
a drug people use calls Shan,
uh,
that I've seen advertised on television.
I think that does a little better than that 20% mark.
But you know,
the patch is not that successful.
And,
um,
uh,
so it's a big deal.
But what was also noteworthy to me about that particular study was talking to
the people in the study.
And I would ask them,
you know,
so why did this make it any easier to quit smoking?
I mean,
it doesn't seem to have anything to do with smoking.
And they would describe an experience that,
um,
put their life and their behavior in such a radically new context.
And they would say that,
you know,
they would say these incredibly banal things.
They'd say,
like,
I realized my breath is precious and that there is no life without breath and
it's really stupid to,
to damage your breath.
And I'm like,
Duh,
uh,
didn't you know that already?
And,
and they didn't know it in an intellectual way.
But I think one of the real hallmarks of psychedelic experience is that,
um,
things you think,
you know,
but,
but really only exists on the very top of consciousness,
suddenly set down roots deep in your subconscious and they become these,
uh,
you know,
convictions,
absolute rock solid convictions that you believe in a way you've never believed
anything before.
And that I think allows people to kind of,
you know,
put flesh on some platitude,
like smoking is bad for you,
um,
and uh,
and killing yourself as stupid,
um,
suddenly you feel it at a much deeper level.
And so I was struck by that and in fact,
Matt Johnson,
who was the psychologist that at Hopkins who directed this study,
he calls them dumb moments,
is that people have a lot of moments but they're transformative.
Um,
and that is that,
you know,
if you've ever had a psychedelic experience,
there is that weird,
uh,
bleeding from banality into profundity and back again that happens.
And,
uh,
that definitely seems to go on.
So,
so one of the ways,
one of the psychological mechanisms that may be at work is this ability to,
um,
reinforce an idea that we all already know or we should know better and make it
powerful enough to actually guide our behavior.
What are some of the apple potential applications or current applications in a,
in a scientific environment or elsewhere that are most interesting to you?
I'm personally tracking potential use of psychedelics,
which is certainly already in motion outside the u s hopefully we'll be
researched more in the u s but as it would apply to say,
opiate addiction,
um,
really,
uh,
problems of epidemic proportions.
Are there,
are there any particular applications that you're paying attention to?
Yeah,
well,
I,
you know,
first of all,
it's really important to understand that these,
that this research comes along at a critical moment.
Um,
our mental healthcare system is badly broken.
you know,
if you compare mental health treatment to any other branch of medicine,
um,
mental health care fails a bismal.
I mean,
it has not extended lifespan lowered mortality.
Um,
it hasn't done what,
you know,
work on cancer,
work on the heart,
work on,
um,
you know,
virtually other infectious disease.
It's remarkable what a pathetic,
uh,
track record it has.
Um,
and with all the,
you know,
use of Ssri in the culture and shrinks,
which here in Berkeley there,
you know,
every other person's a shrink.
Um,
the fact is that,
uh,
rates of depression are soaring.
Rates of suicide are rising dramatically and addiction to,
um,
is rampant.
And so there's a real crisis here and there hasn't been any real innovation in
mental health care since I would say 1990 or so with the introduction of the
SSR.
I's a,
the antidepressants that work on the serotonin system.
Um,
so I am particularly interested as you are in the work on addiction.
I think that that's a very promising and it's an area where we don't have a lot
in the pipeline.
I began as a is,
uh,
another psychedelic comes from a root of a tree in Africa and it has been shown
in,
um,
you know,
still very preliminary research to be useful,
uh,
with opiate addiction.
Um,
partly because it blunts the,
um,
uh,
the withdrawal symptoms at the same time.
It helps you get off the drugs,
but it's,
it's a very heavy and risky psychedelic and it lasts for a very long time.
There are clinics in Mexico that are administering a to opiod addiction,
but there is work,
um,
planned to look at suicide and opioid addiction.
Um,
silicide Bin and alcohol addiction is,
is underway right now in a large study at Nyu that I think bears bears close
watching.
And then there's all the work that's about to happen about a suicide and
depression.
Um,
treatment resistant depression is the subject of study in Europe,
uh,
coming up.
Uh,
and that's,
uh,
people whose depression has not responded to,
to other forms of treatment.
So a particularly needy group of people and then a study in this country,
um,
of,
uh,
major depression,
um,
and,
uh,
that will be getting underway this year.
Uh,
I think if these drugs can,
can really make a dent in those indications,
it would be,
it would be enormous.
Uh,
it would just be,
you know,
and,
and the depression studies very interesting how that came about.
Um,
the researchers had looked at depression in their population of cancer patients.
They were,
they were dealing with both depression and an anxiety.
And the results of those studies found that in roughly 80% of the cases,
uh,
the patient,
the volunteers had had,
um,
uh,
statistically significant reductions in symptoms of depression,
anxiety.
So a pretty big deal,
very strong treatment effect,
much stronger by the way.
Then the treatment effect that got Ssri is approved.
Um,
but when they went to the FDA seeking permission to do a phase three trial in
cancer patients,
the FDA regulators said to them,
we've got a much bigger problem,
a much larger population of people struggling with depression and there's a
strong signal here that this,
that these drugs may help with depression.
So we want you to study that.
Um,
and part of the reason they did that is they will recognize that there's not a
lot of drugs in the pipeline and the SSRI,
sir or,
um,
you know,
losing their effectiveness,
which was never too great to begin with.
We're learning,
you know,
that ssrs do perform slightly better than placebos and their affect appears to
fade over time.
And also people hate being on them.
Um,
because of the side effects.
See,
you see,
you mentioned something that may surprise people and that is FDA support in this
case.
And certainly we don't,
we,
we don't necessarily have to get into Mtma,
but MTV was,
uh,
granted breakthrough therapy designation to which is remarkable,
expedite the process of phase three trials for PTSD.
And that seems that odd with something,
uh,
that came up earlier,
which was this moral panic after the psychedelic sixties and the controlled
substances act and the current legal status of these drugs.
So what has changed?
I mean,
you would think if we,
if we look at the mystical experiences and the piece that people feel,
or the oneness,
the timelessness,
the ineffability one would be inclined to think,
hey,
if you're trying to treat alcoholism with that,
you're just going to give them a state they want to return to over and over
again.
Yeah.
Wow.
That's a good question.
I think it's important to understand that,
um,
psychedelics are not,
the classical psychedelics are not addictive.
Um,
so it's not like you're giving them another drug that they're going to get
hooked on.
Um,
you know,
in the classic drug addiction experiments where you give a primate,
or I'm sorry,
when you give a rat or a mouse,
two levers in the cage and one has food and one has a cocaine or heroin,
you know,
they'll keep pressing the cocaine or heroin,
uh,
till they die,
um,
over and they'll prefer it over food.
Um,
if you make one of those levers,
give them access to LSD,
they'll press it once.
Never again.
They don't want to go there.
And you know,
if you've used these drugs,
your first thought on,
on the conclusion of the experience is not,
man,
I got to do that again.
Um,
it takes months to recover.
and the,
and I don't mean recover,
but it takes months to process everything that happened and it was,
it's so disruptive and,
and so extreme and experience that your first thought is not one,
where can I get my next hit?
So there's that.
Um,
but yeah,
I mean,
it's a weird idea.
You know,
back in the 50s,
one of the,
the really interesting stories that,
that you find if you dig into the research deep enough and the 50s period is
fascinating,
is that,
um,
bill w the,
uh,
the founder of alcoholics anonymous,
a first he got sober after he had been administered a psychedelic or a drug that
some people call a psychedelic called Bella Donna in,
in the 30s.
And then in the 50s,
he got involved with,
uh,
LSD therapy in La and he thought that LSD might be able to help alcoholics.
And He,
and he went to the board,
which he was on of Aa and said,
look,
Lsd,
we should really take a look at it and maybe we want to incorporate it in the
program.
And his fellow board members are like,
are you crazy?
I mean,
that's gonna,
that's gonna ruin our brand,
that's going to confuse people.
So there is a kind of fundamental sense that it seems weird to treat a drug with
another drug.
Um,
but these drugs are so substantially different and they appear to be effective
in treating at least some kinds of addictions that it would be shameful for us
not to do the research and explore it.
Um,
the kinds of risks,
uh,
that are present in it.
I mean,
there are risks,
but addiction is not one of them.
If that's the case,
why have these wife,
these compounds been so difficult to research?
Why are they not freely available?
I mean,
what happened?
They took them off the table for so long.
Well,
I mean,
the 60s happened,
um,
you know,
the,
uh,
there's a,
there's a chapter in the book,
right?
I look at,
um,
the,
the sort of rise in quick fall of psychedelics during the 60s.
And it's a really fascinating episode.
And,
and there it's full of cautionary tales.
Um,
you know,
it's funny,
I would ask,
uh,
I would ask the researchers I was interviewing,
so what happened?
Why was there such a backlash against psychedelics that that research was,
was closed down?
You know,
that never happens,
that you have a promising field of research and suddenly scientists feel they
can't do it anymore and they're told to stop.
I mean,
this is,
you know,
this is kind of dark age of stuff.
Um,
and,
and in and to a man,
and they are mostly men,
I'm afraid they will say,
well,
it's too simple to blame Timothy leary.
And then they'll go on to blame Timothy.
Um,
and he does have a very important role in this.
and basically Leery,
you know,
started studying psilocybin and Lsd at Harvard from 1960 to 1963.
And keep in mind the drugs were legal then,
um,
and uh,
but he got impatient with,
with research,
uh,
with science pretty early on.
And he decided,
well,
you can't really do a controlled study of psychedelics,
so why bother?
And he started studying psychedelics in a net,
what do you call the naturalistic environment,
which meant his living room.
Uh,
and,
uh,
and as happens to some psychedelic researchers,
they lose interest in treating individuals and acquire an interest in treating
the whole of the culture.
Um,
because they start seeing that,
you know,
retailing these things is too slow when they're so promising and they could
actually save us from civilizational collapse.
And you have this exuberance irrational exuberance I would add that seems to
come up in the minds of some people who work with these compounds.
And,
and it's an occupational hazard,
I would argue.
And uh,
and the current generation of researchers are guarding against it,
but take them out for a drink and you know,
they'll,
they'll come around to that place,
the value of these,
the value of these compounds for the whole civilization.
Uh,
which is interesting and they may well be right,
but it's,
it's a dangerous way to talk I think.
Um,
and so,
um,
something else was going on in the 60s.
Um,
and that was that
these drugs,
uh,
were used by the,
um,
by teenagers and people in their twenties.
Um,
and it created a,
a,
um,
uh,
generate what was called the generation gap and a very unusual,
um,
splitting of the,
of the cultures and values of two generations.
These drugs were doing something very unusual to that historical moment.
And something that will never happen again.
Let me explain what I mean.
LSD High Dose Psilocybin or Lsd trip is a kind of rite of passage,
a searing rite of passage.
You feel like you,
you,
you went in one person and you came out another person.
Um,
and it did this for the young,
at that point,
that's who use these drugs.
Not Too many older people use them.
Um,
and um,
normally a rite of passage knits a culture together.
It's organized by the,
by the elders who set up the bar,
whatever it is,
whether it's a bar Mitzvah or a vision quest or whatever it is,
and the youth,
the adolescents pass through that process and then land in the country of the
adults.
And that's how you grow up here was this really freaky rite of passage that was
taking young people and dumping them in a country of the mind that adults knew
nothing about.
Um,
and I think it really,
um,
drove a wedge and the culture and it's no accident that you had this unusual
divergence of youth culture in both,
in terms of everything from,
uh,
politics,
dress,
music,
diet,
sexual mores,
morality,
um,
was different than adults.
And,
um,
and that was very destabilizing for the culture.
And,
and,
you know,
not surprisingly,
the elders reacted with,
with fear and panic.
Um,
and tried to put an end to this,
uh,
you know,
um,
Richard Nixon called Timothy leary who was already a kind of a washed up
psychology professor called them the most dangerous man in America.
That's astounding.
Um,
but you know,
he probably really believed it.
He believed these drugs were,
we're keeping,
uh,
men from,
you know,
going to fight in Vietnam.
Um,
one of the things that happens is that you,
you,
you know,
these drugs make you raise questions about the authority structure that you live
in.
And that was certainly happening.
Um,
so they were very destabilizing and there was a backlash whether Timothy leary
was solely responsible for that.
That,
that seems unfair.
I mean,
he,
he was definitely the east coast,
um,
a person most responsible for it.
But remember on the West Coast you had Ken Keasy,
uh,
the writer,
who is turning on thousands of people in his acid tests and as you know,
is also a psychedelic evangelists.
Uh,
and he was turned on by the CIA inadvertently.
Um,
you know,
they were,
they were testing their LSD and they were paying people 50 bucks to go to the Va
hospital in the Menlo Park or Palo Alto and,
and uh,
and,
and have a dose and they turned on the wrong guy.
Yeah.
Story is so outrageous.
It's like I had never,
I'd never been exposed to the details in your book.
And it's just,
if someone were to write a novel with that as the plot,
I mean,
they'd have to be like Haruki Murakami or something.
It's so surreal.
Yeah.
And the idea that the,
that the 60 is what we call the 60s,
might've been a CIA mind control experiment gone horribly.
Good or bad.
Yeah.
Is,
is mind blowing.
Um,
so I think the drugs would have found their way into the counter culture one way
or the other.
There were,
you know,
there were other routes besides Timothy Leary,
even though he was pushing really hard to make this happen,
but that lead to a backlash.
And you had,
um,
the government coming down hard on it.
Um,
the media who had,
uh,
been,
and this was one of the real surprises in researching the book,
incredibly booster ish about psychedelics,
uh,
time-life,
which was the most,
one of the most important media empires in the country,
uh,
controlled by Henry Luce.
They were actively promoting psychedelics up until up til 1965.
Henry Luce loved them.
He and his wife had been treated successfully.
He published a Gordon Watson's first account of a magic mushroom experience in
Mexico and the 1950s.
Um,
and in fact,
he insisted that all coverage of,
of psychedelics come to his desk so we can make sure it didn't have anything
negative in it.
So,
so we,
the culture undergoes a radical one 80,
around 1965.
And that leads to the closing off of research.
So that begs the question,
could it happen again?
Um,
I don't think it could happen quite that way.
And the reason it couldn't.
Uh,
and for this idea,
I,
I credit Rick Doblin if he's right and I,
you know,
but he might,
he might be wrong,
but Rick Doblin,
who's the head of maps,
the Multidisciplinary Association of Psychedelic Studies,
thinks that the culture has changed too much,
that we've absorbed so much,
so many innovations of the 60s.
Um,
and that the people now in charge,
many of them have tripped.
Um,
psychedelics are not so strange to them.
And that's why you have,
you know,
really some establishment voices in,
in,
uh,
the psychiatric establishment.
Um,
people like Paul Summer Grad and,
uh,
Jeffrey Lieberman,
both past presidents of the American Psychiatric Association,
I've talked about their own use of psychedelics and the role it played in their
intellectual development.
No doubt.
Uh,
some of these regulators at the FDA have,
you know,
first person experience of,
of a,
of psychedelics.
So they're not terrified of them in quite the way.
Our parents were,
my parents were in the,
in the 60s.
And I think there's some
comfort in that for people doing this research that it's unlikely to happen that
way.
Could it happened in another way?
Yes.
I mean,
let's say someone is,
someone dies in this research or there is,
um,
you know,
some,
some adverse,
uh,
you know,
events,
um,
or their suicides a associated with psychedelics which have happened in the past
and could happen again.
The,
um,
the cultural climate could change.
Well,
you know,
we also have Jeffrey sessions is the,
um,
is the,
uh,
attorney general and he's,
you know,
he's not content,
he's not happy with states legalizing cannabis.
How's he going to feel if the FDA comes forward and,
and approves psychedelics?
Um,
it's not guaranteed that there'll be against it.
I mean,
there's another lens you could take to this.
Um,
they are deregulated and that's essentially what we're talking about,
right,
is deregulating a pharmaceutical.
Um,
can I jump in for one second?
I am so curious.
Do you not think there would be incredible backlash if a sessions or someone
else were to come out against phase three trials that are specifically dealing
with say,
victims of sexual assault for Ptsd,
war veterans returning with pronounced trauma and limbs blown off?
I mean,
it seems to be such a bipartisan issue and in everyone's best interest,
there would seem to be some political risk in trying to stop these types of
studies.
Maybe I,
maybe I'm not savvy enough.
Right.
And you've,
and your example is the good example.
I mean the,
the,
the Mtma work or,
um,
PTSD,
uh,
I mean this is,
you know,
is there a more sympathetic population or that you could possibly be helping?
And in the same way,
um,
you know,
uh,
the whole system finally was moved to make it easier to have access to aids
drugs cause there was nothing else that could help.
Um,
I think that yes,
I think there would be a penalty and I don't think it's an accident.
It's not a right left issue.
When you started talking about the military and cops,
um,
you know,
Rebecca Mercer has donated to,
uh,
to this,
to research the psychedelic research.
Specifically.
I think with the PTSD work,
Steve Bannon has spoken out in favor of it.
So,
uh,
and,
and Peter Thiel is as an investor in,
um,
uh,
in psychedelic medicine.
So it's,
it isn't necessarily the case that it's regarded as this left wing thing,
even though it has these cultural countercultural,
you know,
colorations um,
so I don't think it's simple at all.
Um,
but we'll see.
We'll see.
You know,
if the NFL
Yay looks at it,
these phase three results and this is a couple of years down the road and says
that yes,
these drugs should be approved and doctors should be able to prescribe it.
The Dea,
the Drug Enforcement Administration,
which is part of the Justice Department then has to reschedule them.
Scheduling drugs is a political,
um,
determination.
Finally.
Um,
and they have,
DEA has sometimes been immune to a scientific information.
Um,
but I think it would be,
uh,
you know,
it would be a,
an interesting moment.
Uh,
I'm not sure how it would,
um,
uh,
come out.
But I think that,
um,
this work with dealing with post traumatic stress disorder and dealing with the
so called existential distress of cancer patients,
um,
wins the sympathy of the public.
Uh,
especially,
um,
when you're doing it with a drug that where the risk profile is,
is really not very bad.
Um,
so we'll see.
I mean,
I think it's a big question.
Um,
you know,
the idea that there's any kind of logical response on the part of the Trump
administration to anything that has to be factored into.
So the,
you mentioned risks earlier.
I think we should talk about that.
I mean,
what,
what is the risk profile?
What are the risks of these compounds?
What's the,
you know,
the LD 50,
if we have a thousand people in a room,
like what's the dose
it takes to kill 500 of them?
Uh,
well,
there's,
there's no known lethal dose of Psilocybin or Lsd that's,
and you know,
if it kills you,
it's not going to be cause it,
it's toxic.
They're not toxic.
They're,
I mean,
remarkably few molecules have this profound effect and they don't stay in your
body that long.
Um,
so from a toxicity point of view,
they're remarkably safe drugs.
Um,
I think that the risks come,
uh,
are more psychological in origin.
Um,
they are incredibly disruptive.
They disarm your usual defenses and defenses,
you know,
can be very helpful as well as hurtful.
And some people without their defenses get into real trouble.
People do foolish things on psychedelics.
People take them carelessly and they,
you know,
walk into traffic.
Uh,
they,
you know,
they step off of buildings.
Um,
uh,
so I think,
and then there is a small,
um,
a subgroup of people at risk for serious mental illness,
things like schizophrenia for whom psychedelics can be the trigger a and push
people into that first psychotic break.
And I think that,
um,
that happened,
uh,
you know,
wasn't so uncommon with people in their early twenties using these drugs and
that it happens to be the age where this tends to happen.
Would it happen without the psychedelics?
Probably another trauma would have set it off,
if not the second,
secondary.
Um,
but,
but it does happen.
And I think that,
um,
one of the reasons that there have not been any adverse events and serious
adverse events in the thousand volunteers that have,
um,
been,
you know,
have been dosed in the modern era of research is that they're screening very
carefully.
Anybody who's got mental illness in their family is not eligible.
Um,
and,
uh,
so,
you know,
that's kind of the luxury of doing small trials.
You can be very picky about who you give the drug to.
And that's one of the reasons that phase three may not be quite as dramatic.
And it's,
and it's,
uh,
you know,
success as,
as phase two has been.
Um,
so I think that there are people who should not take these drugs and,
um,
uh,
and it's people at some psychological risk.
Um,
that said,
it's,
it's worth pointing out.
There's a story.
I tell him the book,
um,
that very often doctors who in the 60s,
especially,
who weren't familiar with psychedelics in there,
and,
and the phenomenology of them,
um,
mistook panic attack,
simple panic attacks,
which are common on the drugs,
um,
for psychotic breaks.
And there's a great story that,
uh,
Andy Wilde told me.
Um,
Dr Andrew Weil,
uh,
about after he got out of medical school.
And,
uh,
in 1968,
he hustled out to San Francisco and volunteered at the Haight Ashbury free
clinic.
And they were seeing lots of bad trips and people would come in and they thought
they were going mad that they were going to die.
And,
you know,
we shouldn't minimize how bad a bad trip can be.
It's,
it's,
it's a terrifying experience.
And that,
that too is a,
is a risk,
even if it is just a panic attack.
Um,
but Andy had had a lot of experience with psychedelics himself,
and he saw these,
uh,
this,
these symptoms for what they were.
And what he would do is he'd come into the little cubicle with his white coat
and a stethoscope and his clipboard.
And he'd ask a few questions.
And then when he decided the person was not really psychotic,
um,
but was just freaking out,
he would go to the,
he would say,
excuse me,
but there's someone in real trouble in the next cubicle.
And all at once,
these people were like,
wow,
there's someone more fucked up than I am,
and they would feel so much better
and their symptoms would pass.
Um,
so he understood that you could manipulate the experience,
which is of course what the guides understand too.
And,
and rescue someone from what had been a,
a,
a pretty horrifying,
um,
episode.
Um,
so,
you know,
how many psychotic breaks were there in the 60s?
You know,
you hear,
you know,
that there were,
the,
how the,
the emergency rooms were for a period where,
you know,
full of people on bed LSD trips.
And maybe that's true,
but what was that actually,
um,
it may have just been a bad trip and bad trips,
or are first they can be averted with good guiding and second,
they can actually be very useful to people if they're properly analyzed.
And I think the,
uh,
at least,
you know,
the way that I've started to think about this reading your book and becoming
involved with the research is that a medium or useful delineation is safe and
unsafe trip in the sense that difficult,
it does not necessarily translate to longterm negative outcomes in some cases.
The contrary are very much the contrary.
Yeah.
And I want to pause for just a second here to make it an appeal.
If there are regulators,
uh,
lawmakers listening and that is that speaking as someone who I assure you is not
dancing around the Playa and a Thong at burning man,
calling himself a shaman.
That's not my shtick,
but conversely has looked at a mental illness and friend's suicide and friends
in high school and college,
um,
have friends with say eating disorders of 20,
30 years that have been not just mitigated but resolved dif.
I mean at least I can't say definitively of course,
but for years now after say one to three controlled sessions,
looking at the risk profile of these drugs,
there are risks to be sure.
Uh,
but the,
the potential benefit,
the,
the cost effectiveness and the pronounced,
uh,
favorable risk profile is really remarkable.
I mean,
beyond just about anything I've seen,
not a panacea,
but with some very promising indications that,
that make it at the very least worth a researching in depth.
Uh,
and,
uh,
I don't want to sound too much like a proselytizing,
but if you look at,
say,
uh,
you know,
if there are drugs looking at f pharmacogenomics,
if I were to take them,
I could have a fatal response right there,
which are common,
common,
common drugs.
Uh,
if you take grapefruit juice,
which it can certainly change the metabolism of many drugs,
you can have horrible side effects.
And if you look at,
if you were to print out,
let's just say hypothetically,
years from now you have silicide been available and you'd go to Walgreens to
pick up your siliciden.
Uh,
and maybe it's only available through a therapist or a doctor who's going to be
supervising a session.
But nonetheless,
let's imagine this as an exercise and you pick up your,
your little white bag with the pharmacists,
uh,
directions and warnings on the side,
compared to just about anything else to date that I would have routinely
consumed the profile of something like a psilocybin would be very,
very favorable,
uh,
for a lot of things.
And of course we're operating from a place of incomplete information just
because the research has been so stymied.
But the early indicators seem to be really promising.
So I would just say from,
from the standpoint of regulators not calling it the,
uh,
sort of the golden goose,
but this,
some of these compounds have the potential to transform how increasingly
problematic,
often fatal problems in mental health and elsewhere are treated.
So it's,
I
agree with you entirely and I think that yes,
as with any drug,
you've got to compare it with other drugs,
um,
and that they all have risks and we put up with a certain amount of risk to get
the benefit and that the risks in this case,
um,
certainly at the biological level are,
are minor compared to,
uh,
drugs.
We take routinely that,
um,
even over the counter drugs that are more toxic than,
than psychedelics as far as we know.
So I think that's definitely worth keeping in mind.
You know,
because these drugs or illicit,
they're surrounded by this penumbra of fear.
That's a good word.
And we need to,
and we need to like look at them with a very kind of cool objective lens,
which is hard to do.
You know,
David Nutt,
who's a very well known psychopharmacologist in England,
who's involved with the research.
It's in his lab that Robin Carhart,
Harris works.
He did a very interesting analysis of a bunch of drugs and he would compare them
not even to themselves,
but to other kinds of risky behavior.
And he gotten really hot water.
Not only did he say that alcohol is more toxic than Lsd,
which got him fired.
He was working for the government is the Labor government's drugs advisor.
Um,
but then he said,
um,
riding a horse is more dangerous than taking Mtma.
Now we never put those two things together,
but you know,
why don't we have this commercial
six about horseback riding?
I'm just seeing the commercial like this,
the 32nd spot,
safer than riding a horse.
You know,
I think we have to,
I think we're really nuts.
I mean in general,
you know,
any behavioral economist,
I'm sure you've had them on the show will tell you that we're in,
we're nuts about risk and,
and really irrational and how we can front it.
Um,
so it's important to understand that there are risks there.
Mostly psychological people can have very painful experiences.
Um,
but in terms of poisoning your body,
um,
you could do a lot worse.
And one of the portions in your book that really caught my attention and got me
excited was related to the default mode network.
And I'm probably going to butcher this paraphrasing,
so I want you to correct me,
but,
uh,
the,
it was the observation that perhaps some of these conditions that a lay person
is prone to thinking of is separate.
Whether that's chronic anxiety,
chronic depression,
OCD,
eating disorders,
that they may not in fact be a separate as,
as we think.
And I want to say that doctor Tom Insel may have commented on this former head
of the national institute,
uh,
on or,
and mental health.
Could you,
could you just elaborate on that?
Because this,
it's so exciting to me for,
for many reasons that I,
I want to do it justice.
So could you explain it?
I'm
glad you brought that up because it's one of the most exciting things in the
book,
I think.
Uh,
and I talk about this idea that we may be close to or see a path to developing
what I call the grand unified theory of mental illness,
or at least a set of a big set of mental illnesses that include depression,
anxiety,
addiction and obsession.
Um,
and,
um,
one of the questions I asked,
and so when I interviewed him was,
and this is,
you know,
one of the things I was skeptical about that it seems kind of implausible to me
that one drug or one,
uh,
you know,
category of drugs,
like psychedelics should work on so many different indications.
Um,
isn't that a little too good to be true?
Isn't that,
you know,
aren't you talking panacea?
And he said,
well,
what makes you think those indications are so different?
Those illnesses are so different.
Um,
and he said the distinctions between depression,
anxiety,
obsession and addiction are actually,
um,
uh,
there's a lot of,
of,
of a bleeding over from one to another.
And that,
that the,
the names that we give them are really,
uh,
an artifact of the,
um,
of the insurance industry and the deck,
the Dsm,
um,
you know,
the diagnostic manual,
um,
we have to assign a number to every diagnosis.
And so we tend to separate things.
And,
um,
but he's kind of more of a lumper and he,
and he suggests that,
you know,
these could be very similar phenomenon.
Uh,
and that,
you know,
one way a,
another psychiatrist put it is,
is,
um,
you know,
depression is,
is kind of regret about the past and anxiety is regret about the future.
And I was like,
oh,
that's really interesting.
They are,
you know,
the real difference between depression,
anxiety is tense,
isn't it?
And,
um,
so when you,
when you step back to another level and you look at,
um,
the mechanisms that may be at work here,
you begin to see how these,
um,
illnesses may be very similar.
Uh,
how do I mean?
Well,
if you look at a,
again,
go back to Robin Carhart Harris,
his work on the default mode network.
Um,
his premise,
he wrote another really interesting paper.
I strongly,
anyone who has an appetite for a little neuroscience,
um,
should check out this paper.
It's called the entropic brain.
Uh,
and you should put it on your website.
I can send you,
yeah,
I'll put it in the show notes.
And,
um,
uh,
and there he,
his,
his idea is that the brain is,
it is as we know,
a very complex system and,
um,
it has an order,
an emergent order that is to some extent in forced or regulated by the default
mode network.
And the ego is the felt,
um,
you know,
version of that.
Um,
and the ego's job is to kind of patrol the boundaries.
All right?
It's the cop on patrol and it's patrolling the boundary between you and the
other,
you know,
things that aren't you and you and your unconscious and,
um,
and the system,
you know,
has this kind of structural order,
but in many people that order gets overly rigid.
And that brains function along a spectrum from entropy to,
uh,
rigidity and on the entropy.
And,
um,
you have a serious psychological ailments like a schizophrenia.
Um,
and you also,
but you also have childhood consciousness,
which is very chaotic and very psychedelic,
uh,
in many ways.
And,
um,
uh,
and then on the other end of the spectrum,
you get to these illnesses characterized by too much order,
essentially.
And that's depression and obsession and a addiction.
And these are essentially ailments where people get stuck in repetitive loops
that these deep grooves of thought and behavior,
um,
which are enforced by an ego that's become almost punishing,
you know,
um,
to authoritarian.
And so these brains are kind of locked and these other brains,
you know,
are just w way loose and there's a,
there's a place you want to be in the middle there.
There's a point of criticality really where you have enough entropy,
um,
but also enough order and that we go wrong when we,
when we get too far to one end or the other.
Um,
that's his theory anyway.
It's,
it's speculative but,
but,
but has a lot of explanatory power.
And um,
basically he thinks that uh,
psychedelics work by increasing the amount of entropy in the brain and that
entropy up to a point is a very positive thing and that it is the lack of
entropy that that traps people in,
uh,
these very rigid patterns of thought and behavior.
And that is essentially the LSD or the silicide been lubricates cognition.
Um,
it can go too far and leads to magical thinking,
which is also on the too much entropy side.
Um,
but it also can help break people out of those habits.
So there you begin to see the outlines of a grand unified theory of mental
illness and that's,
that's really exciting stuff.
It's a,
it makes me think of,
it's so,
so exciting.
Uh,
because it's,
it's,
it's still offers this tantalizing possibility that you could address many,
many different separately labeled conditions in a similar way.
Uh,
and uh,
I'm not going to name names,
but I was speaking with a,
I'm a researcher in this field,
very well published scientist and the analogy that he used,
and I'm going to modify it a little bit,
but he said that my question to him was what,
what is it,
what is a plausible explanation for why these,
some of these compounds seem to have this longterm reorganizing effect?
Because the,
the,
the half life of the drug so to speak,
is not months long.
So like one day,
what the hell happens where these people in some cases have this persistence of
personality change where they have more empathy a year later,
two years later.
What on Earth can explain that?
And the picture he painted because the mechanisms are still so poorly understood
was,
well,
you can imagine if you're on a,
on a ski mountain,
Oh,
I know who you're talking about.
All right.
Yeah.
After a few hours you have all these worn ruts and it becomes more and more
likely that people are going to use the,
the ruts that have been laid down.
But if there's,
you can't get out of them
or your skis keeps tending back into them and you're yes
and so it,
but if you suddenly have five feet of fresh powder,
whatever,
three fee,
it doesn't really matter.
And then you get up to the top of the lift,
you all of a sudden have to buy,
almost by definition,
choose a new path a year at least given the flexibility to choose your new
route.
And uh,
but taken too far,
it's just like being stuck in a blizzard.
Right?
Well,
let's knock it out.
That's my own admission.
Not terribly original,
but yet,
but,
um,
it's a,
I really need to meet a Robin at some point.
I haven't used to.
You'd need to have mom.
He's,
he's a brilliant guy and I think who will be recognized as a really important
neuroscientists.
Um,
he's just got a very unusual mind because he can do the hard science,
but he's also trained as a psychoanalyst.
He's actually a fraud.
Ian.
Very,
very interesting mix of,
uh,
he got into this because he wanted to show the psychological,
the,
the neuroscientific basis for 40 and ideas like repression and,
uh,
and so yeah,
he's a,
he's a really interesting guy that I think that that snow metaphor is really
powerful.
Um,
we,
we don't understand the mechanism.
What exactly is a filling those ruts,
uh,
you know,
in a way that lasts.
I mean,
I think though it may go back to that image of,
um,
you know,
creating some new linkages in the brain,
some new pathways,
and basically,
you know,
that's what learning is.
It's a pathway in the brain and then you reinforce it by repetition.
So that if you have had such a linkage on an experience and you simply think
about it a lot,
and I've certainly done this in my own experiences,
it reinforces it.
Um,
you can use meditation to reinforce it.
You can,
uh,
just merely just replay it in your head.
Um,
and,
and in time you're creating a more and more,
uh,
resilient linkage.
And,
and that's why I think that the integration a period after the session is so
important.
Um,
you know,
in,
in all the both underground and above ground,
uh,
guided sessions,
there are three stages that,
you know,
they prepare you for it,
they guide you,
they sit with you while you're having the experience,
and then you always come back the next day.
And this is probably the most important part to figure out what the hell was
that all about.
And it's often hard to know.
And,
and many of us take a,
you know,
a big psychedelic experience that we put in this box called weird drug
experience.
And we put it away on the shelf because we don't know what to do with it and no
one's going to help us.
Um,
but at the integration,
the guide will,
will,
um,
have you talk out your experience,
tell the narrative and then we'll kind of underscore a certain ideas.
And I,
and I remember wellsome times I had when I,
when I had good guiding that,
um,
they would buy by emphasizing one particular theme or insight or image,
basically make that linkage a much stronger than it would have been.
And it became the thing that I thought about the most and then was,
um,
an acquired a certain kind of power in my mind.
Um,
so,
so I think that there's a lot more to be done with figuring out how to take
elements from the experience and
um,
and kind of reify them.
I make them more real and more lasting.
Michael,
this seems like a good time to get into those personal experiences and I don't
know where to start,
but I thought since you mentioned themes,
images,
insights,
we could use that as a jumping off point.
And you could start wherever you'd like to start really.
But,
uh,
I would be very curious to hear you describe any of your experiences that,
that,
uh,
ended up being very meaningful for you.
Sure.
Yeah.
Um,
you know,
it's funny,
I said earlier,
I approached the,
uh,
my psychedelic journeys with a lot of trepidation and I approached the writing
of them with a lot of trepidation.
I'll after the fact because I,
you know,
I didn't know that I could,
it's a real literary challenge.
Um,
if you think about how many trip reports you've read,
there were any good,
um,
you know,
you can count them on one hand and a,
so that was the kind of Everest I kept moving toward as I was going through the
book.
It's like,
oh my God,
I'm going to have to explain these experiences in the event.
It turned out to be great fun to write about.
Um,
I really enjoyed writing about it.
It was,
it was a challenge,
but,
um,
of the best of the best sore.
Um,
I had,
just to give you the landscape of it,
um,
I had,
uh,
experiences with,
Lsd,
these guided experiences with LSD,
psilocybin a five Meo DMT and,
uh,
which is a pretty obscure psychedelic that's made from the,
um,
well that is the smoked venom of the Sonoran desert toad.
Yes.
Somebody figured that out.
Um,
and then,
uh,
Iowasca,
a couple,
um,
Iowasca circles.
Um,
I would say that for me the,
the most,
um,
useful,
insightful experience was a guided silicide been,
um,
journey where I was trying to approximate the dosage being used in the,
uh,
in the above ground trials.
Uh,
I think I was a little shy of that.
Um,
and uh,
I worked with a wonderful guide,
a woman on the east coast and,
um,
what can I say about this experience?
What was really important about this experience was that,
um,
I experienced a ego dissolution for the first time.
Um,
I had read a lot about it and dual consciousness and uh,
uh,
and I was curious to have such an experience and also,
you know,
very nervous about it.
Um,
just to pause,
sorry to interject.
So non dual meaning what that means that you're no longer the the observer.
Yeah.
Normally you know,
where the subject,
where they're perceiving subject and everything else is the object of our
perceptions.
Right.
And we have this kind of split and that kind of defines our consciousness to a
large extent.
And uh,
it's rather self selfish way of looking at things.
But that's most of us look and probably many animals look at things that way
too.
Uh,
although we don't have much report,
um,
and uh,
but that nondual consciousness is where that sense of separation,
um,
breaks down either because their other subjects you're aware of,
you know,
I mean,
I've had an experience where the plants were,
I realized they had a subjectivity to and they were,
they were looking back at me in a sense.
And,
um,
uh,
that,
that also tends to break down duel the sense of duality that we go through life
with.
Um,
so,
so this happened,
um,
you know,
this wasn't always a pleasant experience.
I,
uh,
I took the mushroom was a very large mushroom that I eat with some chocolate.
Um,
and it was,
and when she,
she was kind of,
um,
more in the shamonic style of guides,
as many underground guides aren't really is you have a sense of ceremony more
than you do in the above ground trials.
Um,
and,
uh,
initially one of the problems I've had with the underground guides is their
musical taste,
which is just horrible,
very often.
I mean,
to me it's,
it's the kind of music that's fine if you're getting a really high quality
massage at a,
you know,
a top resort.
But for a psychological experience,
it seems a little,
um,
uh,
wanting.
And so she put on this piece of,
of new age claptrap and,
uh,
and it immediately put me in and I thought it was electronica.
I thought it was electronic music.
It turned out not to be.
But,
um,
and I,
and I immediately put me in this space of a computer or video game.
I was in a world that had been generated by computers and,
and it was dark and very sleek.
It wasn't scary,
but it was claustrophobic and just I wanted to be outside.
So there I was in this,
in this dystopian video game going along and seeing,
you know,
all these,
uh,
digitally created things.
And,
you know,
I can imagine somebody who would enjoy this space,
but it wasn't my space.
And,
uh,
and I asked her to change the music and it got a little better.
And,
um,
and as the experience,
uh,
moved on,
I started to get a little anxious that,
oh my God,
I'm trapped in computer world.
How can I get Outta here?
And,
um,
but I remembered my flight instructions,
that's a word used at Hopkins for,
to describe what you're told in the preparation session,
which is if you,
if you see anything scary,
don't try to get away from it.
You know,
step right up to that monster and say,
what are you doing in my head?
Or what have you got to teach me?
Um,
and,
uh,
and it's very good advice and,
or surrender,
you know,
relax your mind and float downstream.
You know,
these,
all these mantras they give you and there were actually really helpful and I
realize,
all right,
I just have to surrender this and I got deeper into the experience.
Um,
and then I,
um,
uh,
am I going too slow to this narrative?
Is this okay?
This is great.
I'm in no rush.
Okay.
Um,
and then I was,
it was very powerful for awhile and I was,
um,
uh,
getting a little nervous about it and I thought,
I'm going to take off my eyeshades.
I'm wearing these eye shades.
And one of the great things about the eye shades is there a powerful technology,
I mean much more powerful than you can imagine.
More powerful than Vr,
virtual reality,
which is not,
they're powerful,
but you know,
it,
it sends you inside.
So if you take it off,
and I took it off just to make sure reality was still existing.
Um,
and,
and to reorient myself.
And also because I had a p,
um,
you know,
suddenly I saw the,
the room I was in and,
and the guide and the plants and the walls and the furniture.
And I was like,
hi reality,
I love it.
And,
um,
uh,
and,
but I had to pee and I,
and I went to the,
uh,
she was score to me to the bathroom cause I can barely move.
And,
um,
when I came back and I did definitely didn't want to look in the mirror.
I was really nervous of what I would see.
And,
uh,
and I didn't want to look at her either and I was just like a peed,
I produced,
this describes the spectacular crop of diamonds because everything had this beam
of light that was,
you know,
being addressed directly to me.
Um,
and then I came back and she said,
did I want to boost booster dose?
And I said yes.
Uh,
and I looked at her for the first time as she was kneeling next to me and she
holds out her hands and other mushroom and she has transformed.
She's normally blonde and she had in her hair,
had turned black and she was this old Mexican Indian.
And she had,
she had morphed into Maria Sabina,
this legendary figure in secondary history who gave Gordon Wasson the,
the,
uh,
the first person,
first Westerner to ever try psilocybin his ceremony in,
in,
uh,
well Haka back in the 50s.
And she had turned into this person and her hands were leathery and her face was
stretched over her cheekbones,
who was quite shocking.
And I,
and I had to look away and I didn't want to tell her what had happened to her.
Um,
so I take this,
uh,
stepped up dose and when I do that and then I go back under and I put on the,
um,
uh,
the shades,
the eyeshades again,
um,
I have this sense of,
disillusion,
um,
that my identity has just exploded into a thousand little slips of paper,
like,
like little postits.
And I was watching it just get blown to the wind.
And,
um,
but I wasn't panicking.
I had no desire to,
to reassemble,
you know,
collect all the paper and put it back in a pile.
It was like,
no,
this is fine.
And um,
I realized that that's what was happening and there was nothing to be done but
surrender to it and that my sense of self was falling apart before my eyes.
But what does that mean?
How can your sense of self,
who's my,
who's,
who's perceiving this?
Um,
and then it got even more extreme and I saw myself,
uh,
spread out over the landscape,
like a coat of paint or butter.
Um,
and I was totally fine with it.
That was the kind of most amazing thing.
And I can't explain what exactly happened because my ego was out there,
but there was still an eye to take in the scene.
And the lesson of it was that,
you know,
what had,
what should have felt like this personal cataclysm,
total loss himself.
There was no category labeled personal anymore.
And I was able to perceive this whole scene with this dispassionate objectivity
was like,
that's the way it is.
Unperturbed and it was this new,
I hadn't had access to this amazing vantage point.
Um,
and it made me realize I'm not identical to my ego,
that chattering voice in our head that accompanies us most of the time.
It's kind of neurotic and can be annoying,
but it's useful to,
I mean,
you know,
your ego is what gets the book written.
Um,
but,
uh,
but I had completely separated from it and I hadn't been annihilated.
That was the amazing thing.
So that to me was the big takeaway from this experience.
There were other things that happened.
I had a,
uh,
a much happier experience with music toward the end,
after constantly fighting with Mary name,
I give it the guide about her musical tastes.
We finally agreed and she put on these buck,
uh,
unaccompanied cello suites,
which are,
you know,
it's a Yoyo Ma recording.
It's just,
they're stunning and they're depressing.
That really mournful,
infinitely sad pieces of music.
Um,
just to chill or nothing else.
and now that I was in this non dual state,
uh,
to listen to music,
I mean,
those words don't describe what happens.
It's to become music,
you become identical with the music.
And I became identical at various times with the,
the bow,
the horse hair bow,
you know,
surfing over those strings of that cello.
And then I,
I went into the cello and,
and you know,
that mouth of space,
that's where all those vibrations come from.
And,
um,
had a,
a total mystical merging with this piece of music and to listen to this music
now sends chills up my spine because I had,
it wasn't Yoyo Ma,
it wasn't Bob.
It was like this universe and I was of it.
Um,
so what does that all mean?
You know?
Um,
ah,
it was,
um,
a powerful lesson in,
uh,
the role of our ego I think in our lives.
And that's what I talked about the next day when I came back for the integration
session.
Um,
I said I had,
I realized that there might be another ground on which to plant our feet besides
this ego self interested.
And,
um,
but I didn't know what to do with it because my ego was back on patrol,
you know,
pretty quickly.
Um,
you know,
doing its usual thing,
keeping,
you know,
my unconscious at bay and making me understand that I am me and that's somebody
else and all,
all the stuff that does.
But she said,
and it was interesting,
she said,
well,
you've had the experience of not reacting as your ego normally would that,
that,
you know,
because the ego is kind of trigger happy,
right?
It's defensive by definition.
It,
it,
Marshall's,
all your defenses and your supposedly in your interest and sometimes it is in
your interest,
but that I'd had a taste of what it was like to not be the victim of those
trigger reactions.
And she said,
that's something you can cultivate.
And,
uh,
and I've been cultivating it ever since.
Um,
so that was,
for me,
that was big news.
That was a big insight for me.
And,
um,
and I think about that a lot and I,
and I think it has to some extent changed my relationship to my ego.
I can,
um,
I know when he's up to his old tricks sometimes and I can spot it and sometimes
I can,
um,
put him in his place.
Um,
and that's useful.
Now,
you know,
30 years of psychoanalysis,
you could probably get to the same place.
Um,
you do a lot of work on your ego,
but this,
I didn't four hours or five hours.
Um,
so that was,
uh,
I,
I now look back on that as a,
um,
a very positive experience that taught me something important that also gave me
a,
I mean,
it was a spiritual experience and I'm not someone who,
who's had a lot of them.
Um,
but that merging with the music was as powerful as spiritual experiences I've
had.
And it also gave me a little insight into what is spiritual experience.
You know,
that term is always kind of mystified me.
Um,
and I think it's no different.
I mean,
I hate to put it in the psychodynamic terms and I don't mean to demean anyone's
more,
um,
mystical understanding of it.
But to me it's,
uh,
Mr,
mystical or spiritual experience is what happens when your ego is put aside,
um,
a spiritual experiences about a sense of merging with something larger than you
and it's your ego that stands in the way.
And,
um,
to the extent that you can subdue it or,
or just put it off to the side for a few hours,
amazing things happen.
Um,
and you realize that you are a part of a larger entity and that the mind of Bach
or Yoyo Mas completely accessible to you.
And,
um,
uh,
and that was a big deal too.
So wild.
I,
it's hard for me to even respond to that because as you noted,
I thought you did it very masterful job of,
of describing these experiences in the book.
If one of the hallmarks of mystical experience
is ineffability,
it poses a,
a quite a challenge challenge to put into prose.
Uh,
and I think that if we think about frozen words also,
you mentioned the psychotherapy and certainly there's absolutely a role to be
played in a function for many of these other modalities.
But it strikes me that they're not mutually exclusive,
but these,
these very difficult to describe psychedelic experiences allow people oftentimes
to feel things or to embody things,
to experience things that would be very hard to talk themselves to as a
gingerbread trail to a conclusion that then allows them to intellectually he's
change their behavior or relationship to their ego.
Things like that.
I mean there are certain things that are difficult to talk your way out of if
you didn't talk your way into them.
And I'm fascinated by our hope,
hope to certainly learn more about why these,
why did these things seem to have the effect that they do and our understanding
is so partial.
Uh,
but looking at,
say you mentioned the treatment resistant depression.
There's a study at Hopkins also that I've been involved with,
uh,
for the last year,
a year,
year and a half.
Uh,
and the,
for instance,
there's a,
if,
if anyone's interested in throwing their hat in the ring,
there's an unfunded study,
uh,
at this point at Hopkins,
they're considering looking at Alzheimer's and even the potential.
But I think they would be looking mostly at its affects on depression and
anxiety,
but there are some people who have,
uh,
postulated that there may be a role in neurogenesis,
in the hippocampus.
Uh,
uh,
Eh,
we're an effect at least from psilocybin,
which is really a tantalizing of course.
I mean,
selfishly speaking,
I have Alzheimer's on both sides of my family.
Some of an acute interest in that.
But if we,
if we zoom out from the,
these individual studies,
uh,
have you thought about how these drugs,
this,
these,
these classes might intersect with broader societal opportunities or threats,
uh,
at all?
Uh,
I mean,
and not pie in the sky
nature or anything like that to avoid that.
Um,
you know,
I mean we have pathologies at the individual level and we have pathologies at
the,
at the civilizational level or the national level.
Um,
and,
uh,
what's striking to me is that the two biggest,
I think the two biggest challenges we face as a,
as a culture are the environmental crisis and,
um,
tribalism.
There are other words you could put on that,
but let's use tribalism.
Um,
both of which are functions of ego consciousness in that what we do to nature
has a lot to do with the fact that we objectify nature and that we think of
ourselves as the only subject and everything else is an object.
Therefore for our use.
Um,
same with uh,
um,
tribalism.
That too is a sense of uh,
you know,
an ego patrolling a border on that.
Everything on this side is us and we will protect it and everything on that side
we're in a zero sum contest with,
so these drugs,
you know,
offer an antidote to both those ways of thinking and it is no accident.
I'm sure that the uh,
the fact that the 60s,
you know,
represented the birth of environmentalism,
um,
yes there was,
you know,
Rachel Carson and the Cuyahoga River on fire and all the other things that were
happening then.
But second Delek consciousness also may have contributed to environmental
consciousness because one of the things that happens is that the world becomes
animate in a way it wasn't before and that the plants and the animals and the
fungi all have their points of view too.
And you feel very connected,
uh,
in a way that makes it hard to be destructive.
Um,
and same with people.
I mean,
you feel connected to all different kinds of people.
So,
you know,
I'm not suggesting we need to put these drugs in the water supply.
Um,
there might be some individuals that we can all think of who would benefit
enormously if they were willing to undergo this sort of therapy.
Um,
but they're,
I think they're extremely relevant to the moment we're in and the problems were
struggling with.
And perhaps it's no accident that this renaissance is coming about at the time
it is.
You mentioned the drinking water.
Uh,
let's,
let's talk about it for a second.
So there are,
uh,
there are,
I've observed,
as I'm sure you have people who are a militant proselytizers of psychedelics who
are,
are prone to the same type of rhetoric.
That seemed to cause a lot of trouble in a,
in the earlier iteration of all of this and the,
in the 60s,
putting it in the drinking water,
making it legal.
You want to go to seven 11 and just get the Lsd smoothie,
uh,
seems like a bad idea to me.
Then you have people on the,
on the far other end of the spectrum,
uh,
certainly in not too distant history,
who would not even consider publishing a scientific study involving psychedelics
wouldn't even consider the scientific merit of a study.
And we,
we,
we seem to be in a very,
uh,
well as you put it at renaissance where the research is finally being done to
clarify the mechanisms of action and the,
the,
the potential,
but also the risks of these,
of these drugs.
And it's so exciting to me having really spent so much time as you have looking
at this,
what are the ways that people can screw this up?
Uh,
do you know what I mean?
Because it's just,
I really,
really think we have an incredible opportunity to decipher how these plants and
compensative in many cases existed while certainly existed,
but been consumed for millennia and how they fit into a world that is bursting
at the seams with not decreasing,
but increasing prevalence of certain types of mental health problems and other
issues.
It's,
it just,
it's such an opportunity that I don't want to see wasted.
Uh,
how can people screwed up?
And what would you,
is there anything given your ask of people up?
Certainly I would say to people,
don't go,
don't find some shaman on like casual encounters on craigslist,
uh,
and order mail order.
God knows what from the dark web and just decide to do it with your friends on a
weekend.
A terrible,
terrible,
terrible idea among others.
And,
and,
you know,
going down to Peru and with the first,
Sean,
you meet,
I mean,
there've been horrible stories coming out of Peru,
you know,
sexual assault of women.
And,
uh,
there was a murder the other day involving a healer and in Peru.
Um,
so I think carelessness is the great threat.
and I think carelessness is part of what doomed,
uh,
psychedelics in the 60s or temporarily doing them in the 60s.
You know,
one of the great lessons,
if you,
if you study history,
is that,
um,
until our own time when psychedelics came along and we didn't have any sort of
conventions or rules to govern their use,
uh,
and many people to get into trouble and the psychedelics themselves,
you know,
ignited a catalyzed to kind of backlash.
Um,
but you go in history and you see that,
um,
these powerful substances were,
were only used in a very controlled,
um,
considered way.
And that you didn't have individuals taking them on their own.
There was always a circle.
There were always elders.
There was the showman,
there was the person who had lots of experience of the,
of the territory administering it to people.
Um,
it was always,
uh,
organized in a ritual.
There was a ceremony,
um,
all these cultural forms,
I'm not saying those ones are right and we should simply,
uh,
adapt those or adopt those.
Um,
they may not be right to western culture.
We may have to come up with our own rituals,
our own ceremonies,
our own rules of the road for these drugs.
And I think that to some extent that was the failure of the 60s.
Now I don't want to paint it with a broad brush.
There are many people who had wonderful experiences with psychedelics in the 60s
who had important and,
and,
and created a,
you know,
great art as a result of their experiences.
But for the culture as a whole,
it,
it led to this backlash and a,
and a and a fair amount of suffering and also the loss of 30 years of good
research that we could have been doing.
Um,
and I think that had to do with the fact that we did not have a proper cultural
container.
Um,
so the question we now face is,
what is that container?
One of them is the medical system.
That's the path that they are on it.
And why you and Hopkins,
I don't think that's the only path.
I agree strongly with Bob.
Jesse,
who's,
you know,
one of the motive forces behind the revival of research,
who,
who says,
you know,
yes,
there are people who are suffering and we have to help them,
but these drugs are also good for what he calls the betterment of well,
people,
people like myself,
people like yourself.
Um,
and that it would be a shame if they're used,
was restricted only to toward people with,
um,
you know,
DSM diagnoses of one kind or another.
Um,
so what's the proper vessel for them?
Is it,
is it a religious festival vessel?
Well,
that's not comfortable with everybody.
Um,
we need to figure this out.
you know,
the Greeks apparently used a psychedelic and the mysteries of Leu cysts of the
Luc and mysteries is,
they're called,
was a,
was an annual,
right,
where everyone who wanted to in the culture,
well,
not the,
not the slaves,
but not just the elite used,
uh,
something called the [inaudible],
which was a psychedelic apparently.
And they had visions and they went to the,
you know,
the afterworld or the underworld.
And,
um,
it was a very powerful annual,
right.
You were not allowed to use the Kiki on any other time.
In fact,
somebody wants did,
they got ahold of some and they had a party and they were severely punished for
doing this because they understood that this had to be taken in the best
interest of the whole society in a way that was,
um,
carefully regulated.
Um,
and so I think that's where we find ourselves.
I think that the,
um,
uh,
is figuring out a way to use these drugs to make them accessible to more people,
um,
but to contain their risks,
uh,
and to,
um,
how's them in a,
uh,
a cultural form that's appropriate to them and appropriate to us.
Um,
that I think is how you prevent,
um,
uh,
the kind of carelessness that led to trouble.
You know,
I mean,
I think leary is sin if he had one was giving up on the idea of a guide and,
um,
uh,
and I think that the,
the guide,
whether it's,
you know,
a friend who stays close to ground or somebody preferably very well trained and
experienced,
um,
makes all the difference.
Um,
and especially as you get older,
I think where you're less of a risk taker,
um,
people in their twenties,
we'll do the craziest things.
I mean,
look at the way they drive,
let alone the way they take drugs.
Um,
but as you get older,
um,
working with a guide is a,
uh,
is at least it was for me.
Um,
made the experience,
created a space in which I could surrender and,
and put down all my defenses.
I'm not going to do that,
you know,
walking around Manhattan.
Um,
and so we have a lot of work to do,
designing the experience,
uh,
and understanding what the drugs are doing,
but designing the experience in a way that is safe and conducive to the kind of,
um,
uh,
work we want to do.
Such an exciting area of,
of exploration.
I'm cautiously optimistic.
I am too.
I am too cautiously optimistic and I,
you and I have both interviewed people and heard these stories of
transformation,
not just anecdotal,
but also in very controlled scientific environments.
And,
uh,
you also hear stories as I'm sure you have.
I heard a story recently and I was talking about the phase three trials with
someone and a their nephew who is a,
I want to say
18 or 19,
probably getting the age wrong,
doesn't really matter for the purposes of illustrating,
but he has his suffered from severe OCD for many years,
which has been debilitating.
Smart Kid,
did a ton of research,
went on to pub med,
ultimately determined that from mc he thought silicide might be a tool to help,
uh,
mitigate his OCD.
And it worked.
But due to the legal classification,
he was caught with mushrooms and expelled from school.
And it's just so tragic in a case like that,
that these tools are not available to those who could benefit.
And I really hope that people will,
uh,
at the very least consider the importance of scientifically exploring these
things.
And there's so many different angles of a examination,
but that's,
that's certainly one,
at the very least,
I mean,
supporting those who are attempting to understand how these things do what they
do.
Um,
and I have to commend you for putting this book together.
And I mentioned this to you in person some time ago,
but there was simultaneously great relief and great kind of hand to the forehead
because you,
you saved me from attempting to write,
w would have no doubt been a far inferior books.
So I really appreciate you taking the time and also the,
the uh,
bringing on board and not relinquishing your skepticism as you explore this
entire world and the subject matter.
I really think that it is,
it is such a critical subject.
It's such a critical time.
So I not only,
and I'm not,
I don't get any,
uh,
vig on certainly up recommend people read it themselves.
But it's,
it's,
it's a book that I think is mind expanding on so many levels.
Even if you never have any interest in consuming a psychedelic of any type,
uh,
it is a,
it is an incredible lens through which to learn more about the mind and more
about ultimately your entire experience of reality is,
is,
is a,
as far as we know,
is filtered through this thing we hold between our ears.
So it getting to know it better,
uh,
certainly seems in everyone's best interest.
But,
um,
I really appreciate all the time that you've taken today and a hope we can talk
about this many more times.
But,
uh,
besides,
besides people reading the book,
which everyone should,
I really,
it's,
I've read many of your books.
It is my favorite of your books.
Uh,
it's such a difficult tightrope to walk and he,
and you really,
you really did an excellent job and so many ways.
Uh,
do you have any parting comments,
suggestions,
asks of the audience?
You know,
it's funny people have asked me or am I an advocate for a second,
Alex and,
um,
and,
and the answer is no,
not yet.
Um,
I'm an advocate,
as you just said.
I thought you said quite eloquently the research we have to support the
research.
There is enormous potential here.
Um,
but it's still has a long way to go.
we haven't answered all the questions.
Uh,
as you say,
this is a book and this is an enterprise speaking larger than the book up to
understand the mind.
It's not to understand psychedelics.
Psychedelics are a tool is Stanislav Grof said all those years ago.
They are a really powerful tool to understand the mind and potentially your
mind.
Um,
and so,
uh,
you know,
I think keep,
keep abreast of the research,
read some of these papers,
read some of Robin Carhart,
Harris has papers.
Um,
and uh,
and you know,
they're more books to be written about it to him.
I don't think you should give up on that idea.
I think you should just wait a little bit.
Uh,
there's so much to be said.
It is such,
I feel like I got every now and then as a writer you get lucky and you hit the
right type of topic at the right moment.
And I just felt like,
oh my God,
I'm a kid in a candy store.
I have this amazing subject.
I'm learning so many things I didn't know.
Um,
and uh,
it was the most exciting experiences I've had as a writer and a,
and I'm hoping,
you know,
that the reader feels the same way.
Yeah.
You paddled,
you paddle for the wave at the right time.
Uh,
I think,
and,
uh,
for,
for everybody listening is I alluded to earlier,
I will include links to not only the book,
but,
uh,
some of the studies like the,
the entropic brain and everything that we talked about.
I will include links to the,
uh,
the international.
Absolutely.
I'll,
I'll include links to all of those things in the show notes,
which you can just find at Tim.
Dot.
Blog slash podcast and a search pollen and you'll,
it'll pop right up.
Uh,
Tim,
I just want to thank you too for your,
uh,
I mean,
you know,
it's wonderful to be interviewed by somebody who is so deeply informed on the
subject and so passionate.
So thank you for your time and,
uh,
and the amount of thought you put into it and for reading the book,
early and,
uh,
I'm very grateful,
entirely.
My pleasure and,
uh,
to be continued.
So I know you have a busy few weeks and months ahead.
So,
yeah,
I was going to be
crazy and,
and I encourage your,
your,
um,
your listeners and readers to come to one of my events.
I'm doing,
I dunno,
20 events in the next month all over the country.
And if you go to my website,
um,
or uh,
Michael pollan.com,
uh,
the schedule is there and um,
please come and,
uh,
introduce yourself.
Wonderful.
I will encourage everybody do that.
They can also say hello to you on Twitter at Michael Pollan and I'll include
your other social handles as well in the show notes.
I will let you get back to your day.
Good sir.
Uh,
but a wonderful to share this time with you and thank you again for writing the
book.
I really,
I really think it's,
it's,
it's an impressive resource end story.
Uh,
so thank you for that and thanks for shining a light on it.
I really appreciate it.
All right and for Tilson and uh,
for everybody listening till next time.
Hey guys,
this is Tim again.
Just a few more things before you take off.
Number one,
this is five bullet Friday.
Do you want to get a short email from me?
Would you enjoy getting a short email from me every Friday?
That provides a little more soul of fun before the weekend and five bullet
Friday is a very short email where I share the coolest things I've found or that
I've been pondering over the week.
That could include favorite new albums that I've discovered.
It could include Gizmos and gadgets and all sorts of weird shit that I've
somehow dug up in the other world of the esoteric as I do.
It could include favorite articles that I've read and that I've shared with my
close friends for instance,
and it's very short.
It's just a little tiny bite of goodness before you head off for the weekend,
so if you want to receive that,
check it out.
Just go to a four hour work week.com that's four hour work week.com all spelled
out and just drop in your email and you'll get the very next one and if you sign
up,
I hope you enjoy it.
This episode is brought to you by helix sleep.
Last year I committed to making sleep a top priority,
trying to fix onset insomnia or continuing to fix that depth of sleep,
quality of sleep.
I tracked a lot,
I tested a lot and I revisited really everything from daily routine to the
surfaces.
I slept on playing with the chilly pad,
whatever.
And when I moved to Austin I got all new beds including mattresses from Helix,
working with the world's leading sleep experts.
Certainly some of them.
He looks sleep development mattresses,
personalized to your preferences and sleep style to make sure that you can have
the best sleep possible without costing thousands upon thousands of dollars.
Helix sleep has recently added a new layer,
customized sleep with the helix pillow,
you all new pillows are fully adjustable so you can achieve perfect comfort
regardless of sleep position or body type or if you're a shifty type like me,
I move around quite a bit when I sleep.
Just take their simple two to three minutes sleep quiz to get started and that
will help ensure that they can build a mattress or pillow that you will love the
mattress,
whatever this be spoke mattresses that you arrive at.
Uh,
we'll get to you within a week and the shipping is completely free.
You can try the mattress for 100 nights and if you're not completely happy,
they'll pick it up and offer a full refund.
I tested that refund policy because I test all of these sponsors and kick the
tires a lot.
We tested it and they came through on making sure that we got ultimately the
right mattress for my body.
Type to personalize your sleep experience,
visit Helix,
sleep.com forward slash Tim and you will receive up to $125 off your mattress
order.
That's helix sleep,
h,
e l I x sleep.com forward slash 10 for $125 off your order.
This episode is brought to you by teeter.
I am so thrilled to have connected with these guys because I've used teeter
products for many,
many years.
I've traveled around the country and the world with tea products and I'm sitting
about 15 feet in my home from one of their inversion tables and we're going to
talk more about all of that.
One of my rituals is hanging and I should say not really that it's a maintenance
and the performance program.
I hang not just in the morning potentially,
but particularly after a day of bearing weight,
whether that includes weight training and Jersey Greg Rec,
world record holder insists on this type of inversion therapy after training or
just wearing heavy backpack around a few minutes goes a long way towards better
sleep.
In my case,
less back pain,
neck pain,
leg pain.
It's not a panacea obviously,
but in version therapy would use gravity and your own body weight,
decompress the spine or the pressure on the discs and surrounding nerves seems
to help with a whole slew of conditions and just as a general maintenance
program,
it's one of my favorite things to do.
So what to say about that teeter?
Why teeter teeter is the best known name in inversion table since 1981 more than
3 million people have put their trust in teeter teeters.
Also the only inversion table brand that has been both safety certified by
underwriters laboratories.
That's a UL and the people in that industry,
you will recognize it and registered with the FDA as class one medical device
and they're giving a very special offer just to you guys,
my listeners,
for a limited time,
you can get the teeter inversion table with bonus accessories,
which I have a bunch of again in the room next to me and a free pair of gravity
boots so that you can invert at home or take the boots with you to the gym.
So these gravity boots,
I have three separate Paris of gravity goods bought with my own monies in three
different cities that I've had for a very,
very long time because I don't want to travel with them necessarily.
It looked kind of like ski boots,
but without the foot portion,
and they cook you upside down so you can take them really anywhere you want to
go to get this deal,
which is a savings of over $148 it's very specific,
so maybe it's 149 you have to go to [inaudible] dot com forward slash Tim that's
twitter.com forward slash temp,
t,
e,
r,
all see a free shipping,
a 60 day money back guarantee and free returns.
So why not try it out?
Remember,
you can only get the teeter inversion table with bonus accessories and a free
pair of gravity boots by going to teeter.com forward slash Tim.
So if you're thinking to yourself,
what the hell is this thing he's talking about?
I can't even envision it in my head.
Well,
take a look at the photos.
Go to teeter.com forward slash tip.